Russian forces are counter-attacking in
the devastated city of bakmu one year
ago this week the siege of another
Ukrainian City that's mariopal ended it
was one of the deadliest battles of the
war tens of thousands of civilians were
killed there Charlie dagada spoke with
two of the Ukrainian soldiers who were
captured and brutalized
for months the soldiers of Ukraine's
azov regiment withstood Relentless
Russian bombardment beneath the
sprawling steelworks complex
until there was no choice but to
surrender or die Chief Sergeant Carrillo
and Commander arson demetric were among
the men hauled away to a Russian POW
Camp were you fearful for your life
this is what crelo looked like when he
was released in a prisoner swap four
months after their surrender
it didn't look like you had enough to
eat
we ate food with no calorific value
mostly with no soul tea with no sugar
and nothing overall I lost 30 kilos
that's more than 65 pounds they won't
discuss whether they were tortured in
order to protect their fellow pows still
inside but it was about to get much
worse Commander arson says some of his
men were transferred into another
Barracks when there was a massive
explosion followed by an inferno arson
describes the scene as a vision of hell
everything was on fire all of the guys
are screaming some bodies are starting
to burn down our boys started giving
medical AIDS
most people are of the belief that the
Russians were responsible for that
what is your belief
it was Russians 100 more than 50 of
their fellow service members perished
the two men again escaped death they
want to see their family then forced on
to Russian TV they said to show how well
they'd been treated
eventually they were freed in a prisoner
swap when their health improved they
went right back to fight do you think
you'll get mariopo back
obviously 100 percent
now it's personal to us against them
not only to win but in their words to
prove the Russians didn't break us for
CBS mornings Charlie dagada Keith